what's our alternative pad you telling
me the new six figures it's three
hundred four thousand dollars how do I
do it do I get another job do I go back
to school hmm
think about the richest person you know
think about the wealthiest person you
know think about that person somebody
you've touched somebody who had dinner
with think about the wealthiest person
you know everybody thought about that
person I'm not talking Buffett somebody
you know it's normally the person
everybody talks behind that person's
back that's the person okay you know it
okay are you ready ask this question
does that person have a job or they an
entrepreneur what makes you think you're
going to become wealthy having a job you
just answered it so have you really
positioned yourself to become wealthy I
don't know but you just answered it
yourself I did not entrepreneur look at
the reality of it they tell us go to
high school have a 4.0 GPA and go to
college to get a degree because
everything is going to be fine
eighty-three percent of college seniors
today according to LA Times do not have
a job lined up eighty three percent of
college seniors today why do you want me
to go to school and spend money and that
is two hundred thousand dollars has to
become a business this College thing why
even four years why can't I do college
in a year and a half I'm never going to
use physics my business has nothing to
do with physics why are you wasting
three months of my time and $700 for
that class but we're not questioning any
of this stuff we're just paying the
money then that father mother that spent
$200,000 on the school and I was working
till seventy three years old because you
think Social Security is going to be
around you think it's going to be around
I tell you it is going to be around but
let me tell you how they're going to
have it be around here's how they're
going to do it do you know originally
when they chose the age for Social
Security you know why they chose 65 does
anybody know this because no one lived
to 65 do you know this one first Social
Security was invented it was because 65
because no one lives to that age do you
know what they're going to do you're
going to see Social Security will be
around but benefits will start at 80
years old you'll see it but in their
government is going to say we told you
we're never going to go away with it but
it starts at 80 how smart is that right
66% of Americans make less than 41
thousand dollars per year 65% of all new
net jobs are not created by the
government or these big Wall Street
corporations they've created by small
businesses since 1995 who's talking
about that who's getting up on TV saying
I'm running for presidency we need more
entrepreneurs we need more van when's
the last time you saw a governor senator
president get up on TV and say American
people please start reading these five
books on how to start a business and how
to manage your own finances
when's the last time we had that why
isn't any politician recommending books
for us to read on getting our finances
in order
why don't we why don't I tell us that I
don't understand that concept educate us
and we'll be free so what is an
entrepreneur in simple words it's a risk
taker but let me skip this here where
did it all begin
Columbus comes to America he was the
first entrepreneur to make it here to
the new world according what history
tells us his mission was to find a way
to trade for spices George Washington
was an entrepreneur manufacturer to
products and his crop flour and distill
this whiskey Michigan was the first
University to offer a course in
entrepreneurism do you know how many
universities are teaching classes to
become an entrepreneur today hundreds do
you know why people are starting to
figure it out they're starting to figure
it out you know who still what
generation is really figuring it out
it's so interesting to me it's boomers
do you know why boomers are figuring it
out because they have the most
experience in the workforce and they
know it doesn't work anymore and
Millennials and Gen Xers are not asking
anything questioning anything they're
just doing what boomers did they're
going to getting a job they're not
realizing the original reason why
nine-to-five job was created do you know
originally you know this nine-to-five is
only a two-year period thing anyone
knows it's like 9:00 to 5:00 has not
been on for thousands of years it's only
80 years old do you know why we agreed
to work 9:00 to 5:00
why 9:00 to 5:00 do you know why we
agreed to work that 9:00 to 5:00 do you
know why daylight hours and you know who
invented 9:00 to 5:00 by what was the
company that invented 9:00 to 5:00 you
should know it you know it
Ford Motor Company at that time Ford was
a godfather of companies in Detroit
whatever they did everybody else did so
here's how was hey Vicki I would like to
have you give 30 years of your life to
my company Ford Motor Company and Vickie
says what she goes like this and she
says what your question would be what
what do I get for giving you 30 years
and I said I'm sorry I'm Ford she says
I'm sorry what am I going to get for my
30 years I guess that's a fair question
okay
you give me 30 years of your life
staying with me at the company I'm gonna
give you a 30 year pension plan wait a
minute so I work for you 30 years then
you're going to give me my income I am
fair deal boom we shake hands good
negotiation do you realize that's what
we agreed to do this raise yet if you
got a pension plan watch this watch this
no no raise you're not pipe you got a
pension plan from your company look at
the age of people that raise your hands
you don't see 35 year olds they're
clueless about it because company said
these twenty thirty year olds know
nothing about pension plans cancel the
whole thing they won't question it
they'll still come and work for us and
we don't even need to give my pension
plan and people are still doing it and
no one's talking about this only people
raise around that high pension plans
mid-40s and up because you were in that
era it's gone we said 134,000 pension
plans in 1985 we got barely twenty
thirty thousand today because they don't
have to offer it to you and I because
Millennials are not questioning it
anymore they're just falling I go work
9:00 to 5:00 my mommy and daddy did it
and the system loves it then no one
questions it people even get up and walk
out what the hell are we talking about
at this meeting I thought this was an
entrepreneurial meeting so why do you
think there aren't more entrepreneurs in
America folks how many of you have
thought about starting your own business
raise your hand what is the number-one
reason why most of us don't start a
business watch the answer fear we're
afraid I've never done it before I can
do it I don't have the money I don't
have the time I don't have the education
I don't have the support I don't have
the I
yeah I don't know how watch this though
why are the reasons why most
entrepreneurs become entrepreneurs why
do you think they do see I think there's
two reasons one is the common reasons
the other one is the deeper reasons let
me speak to you about the common reasons
everyone knows a common reasons the
common reasons are what control the time
I want to make more money tax benefits
family business this one's very
interesting do you know for years we've
been told husband and wife shouldn't
what work together now who said that in
the first place I would love to meet
that guy we're now 300 million of us are
saying that check this out how has it
worked a husband works and works in a
place for ten hours with a bunch of
other people potential to meet new
people wife goes and works in a new
place for 10 hours they are growing what
10 years later you're sitting at dinner
saying why did I marry you I don't love
her anymore
I think we're disconnected 66% of
marriages end up at a divorce do we ask
why do you realize for thousands of
years we didn't have any divorces why
husband and wife ran a business together
we built something what together so I'm
seeing you every day I'm with you every
day baby we're building something
together so at night hey remember that
one thing that we need to work on baby
you need to call Joey in the morning - I
will hey you got to get the Sun - dude
because we're building something
together so anytime husband wife has
grown something together that's exciting
we're not doing that no more because
that one guy they say husband wife
shouldn't work together who is they I
haven't met there yet right but they say
that they say that right Travel did you
know 54% of Americans have never
traveled outside of the United States of
America 54% has never traveled some want
to become entrepreneurs for retirement
recognition nice car big home be their
own boss but let me tell you a deeper
reason why people are becoming
entrepreneurs do you realize in this
room we have Caucasian african-american
Hispanic Middle Eastern Asian we have
different nationalities Christian
Jehovah seven-day LD LDS Scientology
Muslim
catholic agnostic atheist confuses
whatever you want to call it right
educated uneducated Laker fan clipper
fans doesn't matter every single one of
us in this room everybody in this room
do you realize every single action we
take everything you and I do in our life
every single action we take we take that
action with an intention of getting one
emotion anyone knows that one emotion we
want it's what happiness 2007 when the
market crashed everybody lost their
money in 2008 you know what was the most
common word used in books that were
published in 2008 happy because
everybody wanted to find out how in the
heck do I become what happy do you know
why cut you know all these beer
companies do so well because they do
commercials ah when you're drinking with
the single girls and oh and then you
know this is so I one drink you know
Coors Light because I'm happy when I
drink Coors Light for 30 minutes do you
know why the drug business does so well
ooh
when you're small you're so happy you
drop this pill you drink water you get a
massage oh it's great you snort this
thing you feel like you're Superman for
about five minutes
everything's a happy happy happy you're
laughing about it I'm sorry we're all
adults here it's not like none of you
guys haven't seen products this year oh
cocaine I mean it's not like you at the
time we had 80 nowadays in America I'm
sorry we see a lot of weird things today
your kids see things at 10 years old we
used to see at 18 years old so how do
you judge happiness
it took me a long time to question this
I decided judging happiness on the
lifespan of that feeling of happiness
this is 30 minutes this is very short
all of those are short the biggest long
lasting happiness feelings are all
natural every one of them are natural
they're all natural highs all of them
and we'll talk about that here in a
minute
do you know everybody here wants to be
fulfilled do you know everybody here
wants to live a meaningful life we may
disagree on a lot of things there's an a
single soul here who doesn't want to
live a meaningful life any parents in
the room raise your hand if you got kids
hey
what do you and I want our kids to say
about us when we die honestly that they
like us you know they're going to say
stuff about us when we're dead that they
never said when we're alive yes look
some of us don't have living parents and
we wish we had five minutes with them to
tell them some stuff we didn't say none
of us are perfect but you know what's
going to happen we'll be in heaven and
we're going to go and say hey God I
cleaned that cloud am i cool to check
out my kids real quick you clean the
good I cleaned account under cloud is
clean okay go ahead we're good okay good
cuz you know I got good technology up
there right so I'm gonna come home and
say there's my boy see how he's doing
okay he's happy okay he's spending some
time with his wife right now I mean let
me cover this up this is a little
awkward you're gonna step away it's kind
of weird you come back okay okay this is
and he open up the clouds and then BOOM
he's in the car by himself and he's got
his hands and his head on the steering
wheel and it's just going like this and
you're saying why is he doing that and
you can hear his voice dad I miss you
dad mom I need you right now mom
marriage is a mess I have no clue what
to do
I haven't told Mary I don't know how to
pay my mortgage payment you taught me so
much about life I wish you were here
with me I wish I could have five more
minutes with you to tell you how much I
love you I am the man the woman I am
today because of you I miss you mom
I miss you that I love you so much oh I
got two kids man there are only three or
twenty two months I'm now thinking about
this and I know you do as well as
parents because everybody wants to live
a flippin meaningful life
everybody does we may be different but
we want to make an impact with our lives
and you know how we do it you ever met
bitter people anybody met bitter
depressed people do you ever wonder why
some of us sometimes are so bitter and
depressed I used to want to find out
what causes people to be lazy until I
figured out why people are lazy I wanted
to find that at one point why am I so
lazy when I was a kid you know it's a
very simple
does anybody know what causes laziness a
boring life boredom is the seed of
laziness when we watch a boring movie
what happens to us we fall asleep when
you watch an exciting movie what happens
to us we don't fall asleep that's your
life if your life is boring you're lazy
if your life doesn't have a lot of
action you don't have a lot of energy
and I saw that in my life but you know
what causes bitterness and what causes
depression you ever met bitter people
that everything to them is like
everything they're so bitter to be
around do you know what it is let me
tell you what causes happiness and what
causes bitterness and here's all it is
people who no longer create anything are
depressed and bitter and people who
continuously create they're happy you
let me give you an example my mom and
dad divorced in 1989 20 years they
didn't see each other my mom told me I
will never be in the same with your dad
my dad said I will never see her mom
ever again 20 years I prayed I wanted to
have them to be in the same room
together
20 years later they did you know why
because my niece was born my sister
created a child when she created that
child everybody showed up and everybody
was happy
my mom and dad talked to each other with
no problems how many times you seen
grandkids bring families together
anybody's ever seen grandkids what they
do to a family everyone shows up out of
nowhere if we don't create we're not
happy you see people who are bitter make
a list of what they've been creating
nothing they're not happy they don't
have happiness there's not fulfillment
there anybody's ever bought anything
from Ikea you ever bought anything from
Ikea do you ever realize like afterwards
what the heck was I thinking about going
to this IKEA my wife I come on babe yeah
baby see that box yeah baby was just
your point with the box you know when we
said we're gonna make that show up we're
gonna make that that that that little
cabinet together today baby babe we
never make it together you just hand me
the screwdriver baby I mean that's not
making it together so then you go over
there you're all ticked up man you know
what I'm talking about guys yeah so we
go over there like this talking behind
you know under our neurone same stuff
and you look at the box 109
eight parts and and you open the manual
it's in French I don't speak French like
give me an English manual and you start
building this thing right and you're so
furious and you're getting close to what
finishing it and then your masterpiece
is done
and your parents show up hey mom I
created that thing
I am the creator of that day son
don't touch it I created it do not touch
it
hey hey John you know that thing right I
created it I did it
IKEA has become a multi-billion dollar
company because they figured out people
become happy when they create things so
dooku gain is good because when you
create and finish the diabolic formula
whatever it is you're all happy you know
what I'm to puzzles we create we're
happy but those are just actions that
don't make you money another thing we've
realized we need as a community we need
to be part of a community you know who
learn that Instagram Facebook you know
what we do nowadays here's what we do
give me the duck lips duck lips duck
lips boom we took the picture you saw
them puts up his Instagram hashtag
hashtag hashtag hashtag that that that
that that okay great it's a good pic man
it was a good bet one's gonna blow up
watch
they say hundred fifty times today we
look at this thing 150 times a day so go
bro 17 likes and four minutes oh good
it's good oh my god this is good oh she
walk run go check it again 34 we're on
track for having the best when my best
one is 68 69 likes woah Instagram
how come Jerry didn't like the picture
how weird are we right because we need a
community you know what's the last one
you know what's the last one this is why
Russian Empire failed miserably and the
country finally went to Gorbachev and
said get the heck outta here
communism does it work do you know why
it doesn't work as much as they're
trying to convince Americans it works do
you know why it doesn't work do you know
why it doesn't work because we love
having a sense of ownership we have to
have ownership when anybody has been to
a game and your kid scores a touchdown
what does a parent typically do hey hey
Sarris you see that that's my boy so he
runs like his daddy it's kind of like
you know it's an after like his father's
how I used to run up and kind of gain
weight but that was that was me 30 32
years ago
son I'm proud of your body that's my son
hey whose wife is this it's my wife
while you're looking at it it's my wife
my my wife whose husband is that's my
husband don't don't don't you be looking
at my husband over there I'm telling
that's my husband right there okay get
your highs offer hey whose line is it
get off my lawn whose house is this
whose car is this ma you know why
because we need to have a sense of
ownership do you know what's crazy
let me tell what's crazy create
community sense of ownership is all the
activities that create happiness
fulfillment a meaningful life do you
know all entrepreneurs do all day long
it's create they're part of a community
and they own their business that's why
they're so happy how many of you guys
have a friend that invited you to this
meeting here today and you've said this
line to him or other people man he's
changed he's crazy why is he so excited
as if he's joined a cult who said that
they haven't all entrepreneurs are like
that it's not just us go to entrepreneur
events is because they create they're
part of a community and they own their
business that's why they're happy and
that's why most people have jobs they
don't feel that way because you're not
you've just taken orders you're just
doing a regular job and it doesn't
create fulfillment and people are
starting to figure this out so anybody
want to do a quick DNA test to see if
you have what it takes to become an
entrepreneur
anybody wanna do that yes or no you
don't want it we can skip this if you
don't want to do that let's figure out
real quick if you got what it takes to
become an entrepreneur you know you're
an entrepreneur if you're Restless and
no achievement is ever enough who's like
that who is nothing you ever do is
enough right anybody a control freak any
control freaks here hey you know who the
real control freaks are those who didn't
raise their hands you are the real
control freaks we know who you are
give me a break I'm not a control freak
you're a masochist any masochist in the
room anybody knows what a masochist is
any masochist in the room craziness son
that's entrepreneurs sometimes anybody
have a love/hate relationship with money
raise young if you got a love-hate
relationship with money anybody was a
black sheep of the family maybe even a
dropout black no black sheeps here folks
this is the church-going people praise
the Lord God bless this group on this
side no black sheep raise your hand if
you were black sheep and a family and
you did something that most people
didn't do we a lot of them here anybody
but what's called crazy that anyone said
you're crazy yes anyone somewhat
introverted but do you know what that
means also that's like people who have
like seven personalities and you have no
idea who's showing up today okay who are
you today today she's pissed off I mean
I can see the look on her face no no
today she's happy that's good we have
the happy sherry today anybody likes
sports anyone likes competition if you
like competition you have the
entrepreneur DNA in you anyone have an
expensive taste who's got an expensive
taste you prefer Rolex over Folex yes is
that okay with you
yeah you got some taste good at telling
stories strong work ethic anyone ever
sold anything as a kid raised yet if you
ever sold anything as a kid he wants you
to tell us if anybody sold anything as a
kid that was legal just tell us anything
you sold some of you guys raised your
hand went back down would you sell as a
kid Tushar ons to shout on it's okay
what you sell over here as a kid
Princess House crystal that's unique
would you sell as a kid lemonade very
cool what you sell as a kid
you raced hamsters Wow Peter raced
hamsters it's like a lower version of
Michael Vick type of a thing right I
mean that's like and race tambour they
like fighting each other like bumping
heads or no like that's pretty intense
stuff anybody else any other creative
things creative anybody else
anybody's want to tell us yeah tell us
factor would you sell blue yeah anything
you could sell orange your mom's gift
baskets when she went to work did she
know about is the real question and
she's smiling back okay anyone very
curious anyone's ever been called nosey
listen we got a lot of nosy people here
know anyone ever been called nosy
believe it or not and family and friends
is not good to be nosy but in business
if you're nosey it's very very good it
makes you good money and it was somewhat
shameless you could care less what
people think about you raise your hand
it's great to see all these embarrassing
people here who are shameless right
shameless you know what's crazy
do you know how many people I see and
say that person would be incredible as
an entrepreneur but they'll probably
never find out because they're never
going to try to become an entrepreneur
that drives me nuts
I see someone like does this guy really
understand how incredible of an
entrepreneur that can make but they're
afraid they never do it